[Musik]
isny
hinzu kommt ein einbrecher der einfachen
leute ein populist ein nationalist ein
protektionistischer nation ist und will
mit dem auf deutsch gesagt schau stahl
in deutschland aufbauen da macht er sich
viele freunde zunächst damit auf der
anderen seite muss man sagen dieser anti
eliten vor von dem trump beseelt ist von
dem auch seine anhänger die leute die
ihn gewählt haben beseelt sind
das führt natürlich zu einer gewissen
maßlosigkeit und hat sich ausgedrückt
auch in einem oft ungeheuer rüden ton
[Musik]
die pressefreiheit für die demokratie in
einem übertragenen sinne eines systems
der checks and balances der
gewaltenteilung ist ein urprinzip damit
und das macht trump lächerlich er hat
neulich die fake news awards verteilt
das ist eine banalisierung seite des am
persischen golf hat ja gewusst dass
trump der unberechenbarsten von bentheim
würde den die amerikaner in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten gewählt haben
man konnte erwarten dass das für die
politik konsequenzen haben wird es man
konnte erwarten dass der politische stil
noch rauer noch aggressiver noch
vergifteter sein würde das konnte man
erwarten nach einem wahlkampf der
beispiellos war beispiellos
niederträchtig war auch von ihm nicht
nur von ihm aber er hat hier einige
mitarbeiter gehabt zunächst die etwas
für ordnung sorgen sollten aber die
ersten monate waren chaos im weißen haus
viele spitzenpositionen in ministerien
sind unbesetzt bis heute es gibt noch
immer keinen amerikanischen botschafter
zum beispiel in berlin das ist eine
folge davon
und es hat relativ lange gedauert bis
etwas ordnung in dieses chaos kam durch
personalaustausch und anderen america
america first was nicht ganz so schlimm
gekommen ist das ist so die
internationale bühne
er hat ja hat das pariser klimaabkommen
aufgekündigt er hat andere dinge gemacht
von dem die europäer zum beispiel der
meinung sind das ist schlecht wie die
drohung das atom abkommen mit iran
aufzukündigen
alles in allem war es dann aber dann
doch nicht so wie seine ursprüngliche
rhetorik hatte vermuten lassen
also die die abfälligen urteile über
nato eu die sind den ist keine
praktischen politik erfolgt im gegenteil
für und militärischer
verteidigungsminister haben die
sicherheitsgarantien der amerikaner für
die europäischen verbündeten erneuert
wir haben keinen handelskrieg mit china
gehabt das mag sie vielleicht ändern
aber so war es nicht ganz im gegenteil
trump hat relativ viel aufmerksamkeit in
china gesetz das hängt mit nordkorea
zusammen also da sind seine großspurigen
töne sozusagen episode geblieben man
wird sehen ob das sogleich es hat kein
deal mit russland gegeben also alle die
befürchteten trump und putin machten
einen würden ein sonderabkommen
schließen über über die ukraine zum
beispiel die können erleichtert sein
einfach auch deswegen weil trump
mittlerweile so eingemauert ist in
seiner russland politik vor allem wegen
der russland betreffenden ermittlungen
eines sonderermittlers in washington
dass ihr da kaum spielraum hat
ich hoffe dass trump in der lage ist
eine vernünftige herangehensweise zu
machen dass er zum einmal nordkorea und
das ist zum anderen iran
beide können explodieren und zwar im
wortsinne braucht partner und verbündete
das scheint mir passt obwohl es der im
moment brisanter ist vielleicht noch im
falle nordkoreas er zu gelegen als bei
iran
da ist dann wirklich alles möglich weil
er auch darüber regionale verbündete hat
die auf eskalation setzen
was ist die amerikanischen wirklichkeit
man hat manchmal den eindruck die leute
leben in verschiedenen welten und haben
nichts miteinander zu tun
um was für den einen war es ist von den
anderen quatsch und umgekehrt und das
betreibt
passiert ein präsident der eben nicht
mehr auf konsens wert legt sondern
aufspaltung spaltung und tut man ihm
nicht unrecht das war es ein programm
von anderen
[Musik]